yankspeaks is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet
visit expressvpn.com
i don't think progressives in general
have much of a theory of technology
anymore
i think that it's often talked about in
this dystopic way there's a lot of
frustration at the billionaires who who
own it
i often felt you sort of like oscillated
between like a very scary story about ai
and then also like a real interest in
technology as a way of solving problems
and i'd love to just hear you reflect on
that like what should what do you think
the political orientation
to technology in general should be i
love where you are on this ezra
like i i think that ideally progressives
are for progress
and you know what is going to enable a
ton of progress is technology
and one of the fun things about my
campaign was i was making some very dark
arguments about the impact of technology
which i completely believe
but i also agree with you that if you're
trying to make people smarter
healthier mentally healthier trying to
clean up our planet
technology is a part of every single one
of those solutions
in a very central way and the one of the
dangers to me
about a lot of our politics now is we're
each arguing for different brands of
nostalgia
you know what i mean you know meanwhile
time only goes in one direction and
you go to some of the folks who are
working on the future and it is
wild like some of the things that
they're working on are very
positive and inspirational some of them
are very depressing and dystopian
but they're all packaged together and so
i
i love what you just said ezra like uh
you know i completely agree
like we need to be embracing these
technologies at a much higher level and
i'm i may be a part of that
in this next administration if we
succeed in getting trump out of there
wait uh i want to follow up on that
tantalizing i may be a part of that
is there a job you've been talking about
oh so i've had just very very general
informal conversations with the bind
camp about trying to take on some sort
of
technology-facing role right now our
government
is out to lunch on most these technology
issues
and we need to change it
[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to yang speaks
this is zach brownman i was andrew's
campaign manager and the co-host of the
podcast with andrew today
we've got ezra klein on the podcast and
for those of you who have been following
andrew for a while we
were on ezra's podcast really early on
in 2018 before andrew was really
um and the campaign really gotten pretty
popular um
so it's a fun way to kind of look back
at where we were then and where we are
now and how
the conversations changed the movement
around universal basic income
and human center capitalism has taken
off and andrew's completely different
public profile and person in many ways
so it's a fascinating conversation ezra
is
a really brilliant mind um and even when
they disagree on things it's a
fascinating
way of looking at a lot of the issues so
tune in guys you're not going to want to
miss this one enjoy ezra klein on yang
speaks
[Music]
i first had andre yang on the podcast
back in
august of 2018 which feels like
forever ago but i've known andrew a lot
longer i knew him back when
he ran something called venture for
america which was trying to build on the
teach for america model
to push young graduates of top schools
to go
do startups and small businesses in
communities that had not been part of
the huge wealth inequality in america
right go go start things in the middle
of the country
that was a super fascinating guy then
and then when he ran for president
i thought it was interesting did not
expect all that much to come of it
but he did a i think a really remarkable
job he pushed ideas out into the
mainstream that weren't there
and he modeled a kind of political
decency
and oftentimes in the debate in a way i
appreciated
a quizzicalness you you could see him
sitting there thinking like this is how
we do it
this is what it looks like um that i
always thought was
valuable and refreshing uh when andrew
was on the podcast last time we
debated a bunch about ai and what would
you do to the economy um and whether or
not a ubi
would be the right solution a universal
basic income would be the right solution
even if ai did upend the economy but a
couple years later
we are living through a very different
kind of economic upheaval
um andrew yang is no longer a
presidential candidate though he did
speak at the dnc and made some
interesting points there that we talk
about
he's now part of a group founded a group
called humanity forward which is trying
to pilot
universal basic income on a small scale
as he reveals in this show
he is uh thinking about or talking with
the biden folks about taking a role
if there's a biden administration he's
got his own podcast called yang speaks
everybody's got a podcast
now but i wanted to have them on right
now because we've been going
through the series about mobilizing the
economy this podcast is part of that
four part series the final part
um unbox the series is called the great
rebuild and it's made possible
here and there by omidyar network which
is a social impact venture that works to
reimagine critical systems and the ideas
that govern them
and build more inclusive and equitable
societies
my part of it the part i wanted to do
here was about how do we remobilize the
economy postcovid
and so we've looked at the green new
deal we've looked at thinking about how
to remobilize the economies in general
going all the way back to the work of
john maynard keynes we've talked about
what to do for children
and the question i had for andrew is
is something like ubi and economic
mobilization is putting money into the
hands of people which to the extent
congress seems comfortable doing
anything it tends to be that
is that the right way to mobilize the
economy but we also talk about a lot of
other things in here
um from the right stands towards
technology to the importance of making
government function differently and
better to the kinds of values
that drove andrew on the campaign this
ended up being a super fun
conversation you can find all the
podcasts in the series plus
uh pieces from the highlight including a
special issue coming september
at box.com great dash rebuild again
vox.com rebuild
but here with great pleasure is my
podcast with andrew yang
andrew yang welcome back to the podcast
thanks ezra it's great to be here
so in the time since you've been here
you became a famous democratic
presidential candidate went from long
shot to one of the last six or seven
standing in the debates
how has your life changed my life has
not changed as much as
one might think ezra because of kovid i
have been
in with a family similar to to you and
um annie and the little guy is a
little guy right little guy had that
right good
um so a little shrieking little
shrieking guy
yes they do tend to streak a lot my my
first
uh was a real streaker and he remained
so to this day
and that was that was a while ago for me
it's well my older seven so he's a still
streaky seven-year-old
but uh my life has been similar to many
other americans where i've been
in my house a whole lot uh been zooming
a whole lot
and so i certainly feel grateful that i
have
the ability to contribute and help in a
greater fashion than i
would have months ago and super indebted
to everyone who's supporting my campaign
for that and no no no you're giving
you're giving me that you're giving me
the political answer here don't don't
give me that like you represent
something for people now and you didn't
before
you people put hopes in you and you hold
those and you like how does that feel
you've become
something you you weren't before it's
it's a it's a lot of it's a lot to hold
on your shoulders
wow ezra you sound like you're speaking
from experience
did you hold a lot of people's hopes and
dreams over there you wanted
um listen i i got no gang man i well i i
do genuinely feel grateful every day to
to the yang gang and i do feel this
uh responsibility to use whatever
platform or power i have to help people
so we we've been
putting money into people's hands
because everyone knows andrew yang is
all about
giving money to people so uh we've
distributed eight million dollars plus
in direct economic relief
in increments of between 250 to a
thousand dollars in some cases up to
three thousand dollars like a thousand a
month over three months
so that's been a real focus i've been
helping down ballot candidates this is
all getting political again ezra i
apologize
uh so i mean i genuinely have felt a ton
of
responsibility to do as much good as i
can because there's so much
suffering and pain and anguish right now
in the country
and i feel like i'm one of the
relatively few people who might be able
to help
we're going to talk a lot about ubi in
this conversation as people might expect
in giving people
money and how that might re-mobilize
america but i want to talk about
something from your presidential
campaign that i was reflecting on
when you began the run and you and i
have known each other a long time way
before you ran for president but when
you you began the run
i understood it as a campaign based on
ideas that you thought should be in the
national conversation and weren't
and then what surprised me about the
campaign the way it played out
was how much it emphasized you
emphasized
an approach to politics a way of talking
to each other a way of talking about
each other
that felt different and i'd like to hear
your thinking there how your thinking
evolved during the campaign on
on political persuasion and what
interpersonal values were missing
in politics that you felt able
and felt some resonance from bringing
into the
into the race ezra i have to say
it was a real surprise to me
where when i showed up on the scene i
thought i would be
received and perceived as to the left of
bernie
where i thought that uh people would say
even bernie you didn't go so far as to
say give everyone money
like bernie stop short of that and that
that i i was somehow going to be the
most
progressive seeming candidate and i used
to joke that i was going to be like
bernie but
younger and more asian but that's not
how i was
received at all i was received actually
as this
re-alignment type figure
where i was talking in terms that other
candidates were not
and what's funny is for me it was just
the way i communicate
so people listening this could take that
for what it is
um but i was arguing from facts and
figures
and my concern about the fact that we'd
eliminated
5 million manufacturing jobs 4 million
due to
automation primarily in the swing states
that decided the 2016 election
and just by my talking the way i talk it
ended up
being a different approach to politics
that some people got excited about
so that was something i did not
anticipate uh and
i did end up learning from it and
adapting to it
and i learned that there are a lot of
people that do want us to approach
politics in a different way than we have
been over the last number of years
so this is a weird thing to tell
somebody but i don't think that's
actually what it was for you and you and
maybe
but as as somebody who also built some
career
on being good at communicating in facts
and figures and also in the aesthetic of
communicating in facts and figures right
i didn't have a math pin but wonk blog
and charts and
you know there's both the reality of it
which you try to try to do in a real
substantive way and also
the signal of it there are other people
who did that too i mean elizabeth warren
is a very facts and figures oriented
candidate what seemed to me to to
resonate
uh around you with folks that i did not
expect was that
you really never seemed to dislike
anybody on the campaign trail
you didn't dislike people didn't agree
with you you didn't dislike people who
insulted you you didn't dislike the
people you were running against you
spoke
um fondly and with a lot of empathy
of towards people on the other side the
way you framed
your your your policies had that
dimension you're talking about the
bernie sanders and imagine yourself to
the left of him
but one way people experience politics
isn't just ideological it's also
on this axis of confrontationalness
and you had a pretty um distinctive like
left policy agenda
but on the confrontational axis you were
way down right you would talk to people
democrats would
rarely talk to go on programs they would
rarely go on and and even now
on twitter i think you very
self-consciously cultivate a very nice
persona in a very unnice space
and i'd like to hear a bit about how you
you think about that because whether
it was all authentic i think there's at
least some recognition that it has power
now
and given that it's a pretty basic thing
i think it probably had more power than
you would have expected or certainly
than i would have expected
wow ezra i hadn't thought of it in in
those
terms but i mean you've known me for a
while so you know that
the nice thing is a complete facade
that i'm actually naturally very bitter
now it's it's the case that i like most
americans
and then i think that there have been
massive problems that have been built up
over decades and decades
and you wrote a book on polarization and
why we're polarized
and i feel like people have gotten
driven into different corners and pitted
against each other in a way that's
unproductive i naturally don't get angry
at people that disagree with me
i kind of expect a degree of political
uh
asynchrony because you know it's like
not like someone's gonna believe
everything you believe
and one of the things that i did find
running for president was that
the media would often try and goad me
into conflicts
it would be like this person said this
what do you think about that and and the
dynamic was supposed to foment an
expression of
outrage and then i would say something
that seemed to me to be like
the natural reaction but i just think
that the outrage
cycle is very very negative
uh and i think a lot of americans
including me are very tired of it
but i can genuinely say it wasn't really
a strategy on my part
and it's not a strategy now except in so
far as
when i'm putting out a message i just
find it
more productive for me to be positive
than for me to throw a rock at somebody
it always struck me too that it
reflected in part the media you came up
through so i think when most democrats
run for president they think about
getting coverage on
you know msnbc and in in democratic or
liberal aligned publications which have
which tend to reward a more
confrontational approach and that's true
also for
for centrist publications right you you
have a great story
on your blog about being at an early
iowa event and
like all the reporters are there to hear
michael avenatti including like the
centrist reporters who just want
conflict
but you came up i mean you're on my on
this podcast pretty early in your
campaign but you did joe rogan's podcast
my friend sam harris
um you were on like a lot of youtube
world things
and that's some that's a it's a very
political space and sometimes it can be
even an angry space but it's
like a more mixed space you have like a
lot of fans on reddit and 4chan
and that struck me as uh like informing
your approach way through that that
those are different worlds to talk to
where people have different political
concerns
and it always struck me that you ended
up representing a slightly less
polarized media
in what ended up working for you and
what you then
were rewarded for saying and and
representing in politics
ezra i genuinely went where
they would have me i guess where
initially
the like the the msnbc's and cnns
um uh and you know centrist publications
were not very excited to have me on
frankly so if you were me and you were
like who wants to talk to me
like hey do you want to talk to me it's
one reason i'm grateful to you because
you had me on
when others were not and so i'm grateful
to you and i've always seen you as a
very very
smart back-driven purveyor of
what you regard as truth you know and
it's you know it's
one reason i appreciate you in this
conversation so much
and i did not get that vibe from
from some other outlets and journalists
and so
you know it really was a necessity being
the mother of invention where i would
talk to people that would have me on um
and a lot of those folks were youtubers
and podcasters and folks who didn't have
a cable network behind them
yeah it's a and it worked i mean i want
to get to ubi so we won't spend all
the time looking retrospective of your
campaign but but it did just strike
me as i thought you and pete buddha
judge did the best job of this and you
did something differently right i don't
think p buddha judge would have gone on
ben shapiro's show and
and debated circumcision like that
wasn't his vibe but there was a
like joe biden for his virtues has a
very
old media view of politics and also
doesn't do that much media
and a lot of democrats would come up
through through the ranks for a long
time
like they saw media very much i would
call it the way it was in 2005.
and now there's this burbling fractured
and it can be very
polarized but it also can be very mixed
up in a way that can be useful
world out there and that if you're a lot
of it has
much more audience than people i think
in the mainstream media recognize
you know what some of these folks on
youtube are able to command is in the
millions it um
it it rivals the cable networks but it
doesn't have
like the mainstream establishment uh
respect
that say a cable network does and so it
gets ignored
but it's no worse a way to to to reach
people and i think reddit had that
quality for you too
you're very big on rashes on reddit
yesterday and you're involved i guess in
some california data privacy initiative
and had 23 000 upvotes just noting that
you were part of it
so these are these are pretty different
worlds and and i wonder how much you
think
the democratic party or just traditional
politics politicians in general
are missing them and and leaving these
worlds unspoken to
well this to me is uh something we
should talk about more ezra
because i think the shifting media
landscape is
going to impact politics very
dramatically
and some folks are going to be late to
it like you're on top of it just from
that line of questioning but
if you look at the cable news audiences
um you're looking at the low millions
and it tends to be like the same
two million people over and over again
and you're talking about
a massive population of you know tens of
millions of voters and so you hit it on
the head
where if you look at the audience of
some of the biggest
podcasts uh it goes into the millions it
is higher uh than the cable newscasts
and the the cable newscast drive this
media narrative
bubble that then gets self-reinforcing
and then everyone looks out
out and says like hey aren't you
concerned about whatever the heck we
were concerned about yesterday and
meanwhile like they're just listening to
joe rogan or whoever
you know like that they they're getting
a very different
perspective and they're hearing about
issues that
are more relevant to them than a lot of
the dc
oriented issues the biggest example of
that on the trail was impeachment i
don't think i got a single question
about impeachment
the entire time and then and this was
when he was actually getting impeached
you know so so there are different
conversations happening
and it would be very beneficial for
politicians generally but democrats in
particular to start trying to broaden
their universe
because what you don't want to do is
just end up in a world where just
talking to each other and then wondering
why
no one's listening to you and that's the
danger and one of the things that
i like about these different worlds as
somebody who i try to spend a certain
amount of my media diet
in subcultures that are not my main one
um
because i think it's important to know
how their argumentative universes work
and what they consider important and
unimportant
and this to me was always the secret of
your campaign that people didn't quite
realize
uh that politics washington politics
has developed a set of things that it
considers like the questions of the day
the week the month a year
um so you know at a certain point it's
impeachment which is very very
it was important like i ran an
impeachment podcast and i think it's
important what was happening there
um but taxes health care i mean these
are these are real things
you might ask how did this guy andrew
yang get on joe rogan and some of these
other shows
because he doesn't allow just anybody on
that's a big show he has a lot of
options about who comes on
and there's this whole world that is
very uh focused
on ai risk and what that's going to do
and how that's going to change things
and when you came up and wanted to
move that up as an issue in politics
increase
like as a political scientist would say
increase in salience and politics
there was a world of people there for
that because they were already having
that conversation but nobody in politics
was like
politics reflected the the set of
issues that washington thought was
important and understood how to talk
about
but it's not the only set of issues
people care about and so then there are
these whole worlds
that are really underserved in terms of
their concerns and
like what always struck me as an
interesting bypass you took into this
was
like the value of your campaign to me
was it it elevated concerns that deserve
more attention to politics than they
typically
get not just solutions but concerns and
you know that i have a different view
on a lot of the ai economic risk than
you do at least somewhat
but um but there's no doubt that it
should be talked about
and so you went where people were
talking about it and i think there was a
lot of surprise
that so many people were so uh were so
concerned and so
engaged on this and so ready for a
candidate to try to say
no this should be one of the ten issues
we talk about like let's move something
else out of the frame
yeah that's right ezra where if you talk
to techies they're much more concerned
about
ai and as you know the the central
argument-wide campaign around automation
than a lot of other americans
and they were happy to talk to a
political figure who was
talking about something that they'd been
thinking about for months or years
and one of the funny byproducts of it
all was that
i ended up having conversations with
people that didn't feel terribly
political if you know what i mean it was
like look
like what's going on uh with ai like
what should we be concerned about
like what does that competitive
landscape with china look like over time
and because of that i ended up reaching
audiences that
generally did not consider themselves
super political
and hopefully i did broaden the range of
concerns that
we should be looking at as a country it
wasn't very deliberate on my part i mean
i just cared about what i cared about
[Laughter]
went to folks who also cared about it
but it is a sign
how both dc and the media
have this relationship where there's
like a set of prescribed concerns that
may or may not line up with
the concerns around the country
when i was running for president i slept
on a lot of mattresses
there were a lot of mattresses involved
we never got bed bugs which was
especially in the early days a minor
mirror thank goodness for that airbnb
uh hotels motels whatever it was
i gotta say a good mattress makes a
pretty freaking huge difference
and if you want uh the mattress of the
future that's personalized to you that
you get ordered and it comes in a box
then it pops out
like some kind of uh animate mattress
what are helix sleep it's great we've
got one
you personalize it to to you it gets
sent to your door
is the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2019
and 2020 by gq and wired so if that
doesn't make you excited for helix sleep
they'll also just take it back if you
don't like it
it's almost too good to be true go to
helixsleep.comyang and take their two
minute sleep quiz
who doesn't want to answer questions
about how you sleep uh and they'll match
you to a customized mattress i
thoroughly enjoyed that by the way yeah
it's fun it makes you think about it
like
the quiz is awesome it's like do i sleep
on my back no i see them on my side
anyway keep going
yeah i know you think about it i'm a
front sleeper myself no i'm not
front sleepers are no i really i
actually i don't even know what that was
you're asleep anywhere guy if the
campaign bus is any indication you are
i'm asleep all positions
standing at any time you give me a
chance crouched
uh yeah so so helix is offering up to
200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com yang that's helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep dot com slash yang for up to 200
[Applause]
off
one of the things that i think politics
systematically
under rates and importance and and tends
to be very bad at talking about is
technological change just
in general how important it is what is
happening with it we
functionally live in a gerundocracy
where um i think nancy pelosi's
80 trump is 74. joe biden is 77.
mitch mcconnell is in the upper 70s i
think he might be 77.
like this is not the most tech forward
leadership
uh group you could possibly imagine and
so a lot of what is changing in
technology which is really important i
think it gets
underplayed so let's have a little bit
of a conversation
there ai how has your thinking changed
on it in the past few years
compared to you know two years ago or
whatever it was when we talked
do you think the landscape there has
changed um do you think there are things
people should know that have happened
a lot of the things i was concerned
about have
now come into full view because of the
pandemic
and you know that companies that were
considering investing
in ai and robotic meat packers and the
rest of it
and robot aisle cleaners in the grocery
store
now those companies are accelerating the
investments
and the example i use is that
now if you get a domino's pizza and a
self-driving car
you're excited because you had less
human contact whereas before it seemed a
little bit creepy
same with the self-checkout aisle and
if you look at ai that there's this new
release that now
can do a lot of writing and basic
summaries on a level that's
indistinguishable from
human journalists you're talking here
about open eyes gpt-3 yeah
yeah yeah opening eyes uh gpt3 yeah so
if people haven't heard of this i'm
going to put in show notes
my colleague kelsey piper did a great
piece on this but it's
surreal let me put it that way what it's
able to do in terms of language
processing is
wild and two years ago if you'd asked me
hey
is software gonna get to this point i
would say i would have said yes
um but then you could still argue over
it you know what i mean uh
and now two years uh later it's here
and you can see the commercial potential
of this technology
one of the reasons why i was so
concerned about the impact of ai on our
labor force ezra is that i know
how many frankly inefficient jobs there
are in a lot of these major companies
where if you gobble up another company
and you have two different systems
you might keep dozens even hundreds of
folks around just to keep the systems
talking
to each other like this there's a lot of
weird stuff
when you get into the bowels of some of
these organizations
and i knew that over time ai could end
up making a lot of those types of jobs
less and less central the arguments
about
human labor and ai they tend to be
non-market driven and kind of romantic
you'd be like oh you know
like you can ever replace a human who
does what ezra does or
what andrew does or whatnot but you know
a lot of our work is more replaceable
than we like to think
and what's funny is if you ask americans
about this they will actually say a
majority
of other people's jobs are automatable
and subject to technological replacement
and then if you ask them about their own
job the vast majority will say not my
job uh you know that's just the way
we're wired
it's why i'm fleeing to the high ground
of podcasting i mean they're gonna come
for the calmness way before they come
for the podcasters it's much
definitely much harder for ai to have a
good conversation than for it to just
write up a
write up a take on the gdp report anyone
anyone like us we're already at the top
of the pyramid you know what i mean like
if you have a podcast with a significant
audience
you're you're you've already made it to
a certain point like and if you think
about all the
folks who are coming of age right now
like the younger versions of us who are
graduating from college right now it's
like you know it's
the winner-take-all economy applies in
many spaces including
uh the ones that you and i occupy oh
absolutely so i i have some slightly
different views
on how many jobs are automatable and
and even what the coronavirus uh is
going to do
uh to the desire for human contact i
think in many ways you're seeing
how irreplaceable at least parts of it
are um how much people want it
but people can listen to our previous
show to hear
our views on that but what i do want to
dig into here is something that
you were hitting which i where i do
think it's really true which is that
we are going to see and are seeing a
bunch of jobs get automated
in a shock-like way because people need
to find ways at least in the near future
to do things with less human contact
between human beings
and we're seeing this moment that is a
very deep
reminder that people don't have control
over their economic
fortunes that all of a sudden a pandemic
virus
or something technological advance could
happen in your industry that lays you
off or that destroys the economy in your
town
and so you really get into i think your
argument now for
for ubi um which ai chronovirus like
these things begin to almost operate as
like metaphors for just a shock and what
happens to people during a shock and do
you want to leave it up to congress to
argue about
expanding ui benefits during a shock so
there's been a lot of movement actually
in the andre yang direction
or as i often like to think about at the
annie lowry direction
towards just giving people money um
during this uh during this pandemic
and that's been a real policy shift that
is not how we've done things during past
crises
so i'd like to hear you talk a little
bit about why you think that's happened
and what you think we can learn from its
performance so far
i am very happy for it to be the annie
lowry direction
[Laughter]
and certainly you know i'm thrilled
about anyone who gets on board doesn't
matter
why or what you call it you know that
there are now dozens of mayors around
the country who are championing
guaranteed income michael tubbs the the
original but there are now dozens of
folks keisha lance bottoms
eric garcetti and around the country who
are committed to universal basic income
pilots
and the reason ezra is that now is just
common sense where you look around and
you see that there are tens of millions
of americans who have gotten shoved out
of the
labor force because we don't need as
many
bartenders airline attendants security
guards
ushers personal trainers you name it
like there's so many jobs that required
physical proximity that now just don't
make sense and like you said it's not no
one's fault
and so then you look around and say how
are we going to get economic resources
into the hands of
these millions of people and cash relief
is the only sensible solution
and twelve hundred dollars in april uh
going out
had a really positive effect on many
households and on
propping up our economy but we need to
make that regular
recurring predictable we've been living
off of the first
cares act but then now that benefits
have elapsed
you're going to see distress and
disintegration
pick up in many many households and
communities
and there really is no feasible way to
help so many households manage this
except for direct cash relief and it's
not just you me and annie
uh and mayor tubbs at this point last i
i saw
76 of americans are pro cash relief
during the pandemic uh and 55
are now pro-universal basic income so
it's no longer the magical asian man
making this case
it's the majority of americans realize
it's common sense and something we need
to do
so there's a big jump between
using cash transfer for relief which is
what we've seen during the pandemic and
as you say is already
uh republicans already moved into a
chance of opposition on it even though
the pandemic is ongoing
and moving to a basic income floor
and right in the middle of that jump is
this argument that republicans are now
making
on the ui on the unemployment insurance
why they won't extend the 600
which is that if people can get paid
and can support themselves in their
lives without working they won't work
and the point of american economic
policy should be getting
as many people to work as we can
no matter what no matter what job they
have to take
and so what is your argument to them
what is your argument to the republicans
who say
look relief is fine but we do not want
to be paying people not to work because
we want people working
i would agree and say the last thing you
want to do
is tie economic relief to job status or
employment status
so if you put cash into someone's hands
and say you can have this cash
unless you start working then it
actually is
a detriment to them going back out there
as quickly as possible in some cases i
mean most people will still just be
panicking until they find a job and so
to me this effect is overstated and
overblown
but to the extent it exists you are
right now
tying a lot of this cash to employment
status i would say make the cash
unconditional
and then you'll have a baseline and if
you go out and get that part-time job
because it's not ready
to be a full-time job because the
bowling alley or the retail store is not
at
full reopening yet then
you get to keep that money as opposed to
right now saying
well wait a minute if i take this job
then i stop getting benefits
so the problem right now is our existing
legacy
infrastructure that ties the cash relief
to
not working but but i think you're
you're underselling what's happening
there a little bit it's not just legacy
infrastructure
it is on one level i would call it a
value that people hold
on another level i would call it a
political argument people make
i think there are different ways to
frame it but there is a
long-running belief in american politics
that
money should be tied to work and you
mentioned being to the left of bernie
sanders
i remember in 2016 sometimes you would
go to bernie sanders
homepage and you would get this splash
right like the the pop-up would be
nobody should work 40 hours a week and
live in poverty which isn't nobody
should live in poverty because we give
them money not to live in poverty it's
that work should pay right the minimum
wage should be higher the eipc should be
higher
and so that's a that's not just a thing
you see on the right it's a thing you
see on the left it's a
view joe biden largely holds um it's a
view many liberals have traditionally
held
that not only is it like a good thing to
push people into labor force but also
politically
people just don't like the idea of folks
getting something for nothing they don't
want to see
their cousin or their neighbor laying
about and so i think that's the argument
that
how do you rebut that argument the sort
of more moral values argument not just
the the technical argument
i i think that argument is uh to one of
the earlier points you made just really
really out of date
you know it harkens back to some 70s or
80s notion of employment where
if you work for a company they'll treat
you right and give you benefits and
you'll be able to
to live a fine middle class life in an
era when most of the jobs that have been
created are gig and contract and temp
jobs
and they don't have benefits in many
cases
it also doesn't include caregivers and
stay-at-home parents like my wife evelyn
who's been at home for
a while in part because one of our boys
is autistic
and was very very much in need
of her time so to to me this is not an
argument that
frankly like liberals and progressives
should fall for where it's like oh
i mean i'm i 100 agree with a statement
that if you're working
full-time in the united states of
america you should not be poor
but i also think that my wife works
harder than i do um
you know most every single day and there
are moms around the country are in the
same boat and they should not be poor
either
and trying to define work as
this anachronistic uh show up to an
office or factory 40 hours a week is
missing the evolution of our economy
that's been happening for decades
why a ubi rather than a negative income
tax i am a huge fan of a negative income
tax
and if that's where knitted out i'd be
thrilled i prefer a ubi for
multiple reasons i even think it's
probably a better sell politically but
like the the reasons why i prefer the
ubi
are that uh it lowers the administrative
burden because
you don't need to figure out how much i
made last year this year
it removes any strange shenanigans in
terms of
trying to report a low income like if
you have
like a couple for example you could be
like how about i work and you don't work
and
we'll make it so you don't have any
income and then we'll make it so you get
some money the following year uh and it
alleviates the timing of payments issue
because if your circumstances change
from one year to the next you're not
likely to get your negative income tax
immediately
when you might need it immediately and
politically i think it's more appealing
to be able to say to everyone look you
have intrinsic value this is how much
you get
for being an american a human being
but i'd be thrilled with the negative
income tax if if that's where we wound
up i mean if you alleviate
and eradicate poverty i am all for it
[Music]
here at yang speaks you know we're big
fans of the fact that your data should
be yours
i'm i'm right now championing a
california
proposition prop 24 to help make sure
that
we can actually fight for our data and
privacy rights
one way you can make sure your data
stays private is by using
a virtual private network and the vpn we
recommend
here at yankspeaks is expressvpn it's
the number one rated vpn
by wired and cnet and one
bonus about using this thing is that you
can actually change your online location
so you can control
where sites think you are and then you
can watch
content that's only available someplace
else so that's right if you want to
be getting netflix from the uk
or japan for anime or anything that's
available in some other part of the
country
you can do it and keep your data safe by
using expressvpn
i know it's pretty wild it's essentially
like planning a flag where the internet
thinks you are
and then no one's the wiser as to what
you're seeing or doing
go to expressvpn.com yang to get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free
expressvpn.com yang so
rick and morty is on the french netflix
and the fresh prince of bel air is on
the australian netflix so i've been
having a blast
with this check it out it's kind of cool
stream shows that you don't normally get
a bit of a hack here so
expressvpn.comgang get your extra
three months
[Applause]
do you think the us government has a
spending constraint on it could could we
do
a ubi and agree new deal and medicare
for all
and just put it on the put it on the
national credit card or
do we have limited resources and we have
to make choices between them
well the argument i made on the trail
ezra which i sense you'd agree with
is that we have a revenue problem in
that the biggest winners
in the 21st century economy are paying
zero or near zero in taxes very often
and the most prominent example is amazon
the trillion dollar
company that paid zero in federal taxes
last year and so what i said to folks is
like look
if you have amazon paying zero taxes
you're going to have affordability
problems for sure
and that if you harness the gains from
the amazons and apples
and netflixes of the world then
you have a lot more revenue to work with
very quickly and then if you put that
money into people's hands
that money does not disappear it ends up
going right back into the
local economy in the form of car repairs
and daycare expenses and
the occasional meal out and those
businesses all then create more
opportunities and can create virtuous
cycles that help end up
creating jobs and human well-being
but the big thing ezra i think is that
we need to stop
measuring our economy in terms of these
narrow economic outputs
where if you try to figure out what's
good for us by what's good for the stock
market then you're lost
uh and so if we wait but but i'm going
to hold you on i'm going to hold you on
this argument before you go into it
because i want to stay on the
i'm not measuring our economy by narrow
economic outputs by gdp right here i'm
the the question i'm asking is um is can
we afford it i know we need to
pay for yeah do we need to pay for
things like this and what i would say is
i know
the the corporate tax data on this stuff
you know well enough to say
that the list of things i just gave you
medicare for all ubi and green new deal
you could do everything that the folks i
know who want to tax corporations and
rich people quite a bit more
think we should do and in most cases i
want to do those things too and you
wouldn't come near paying for this set
of things so at some point you have to
there is a question of whether or not
these things are worth raising taxes for
which i often think they are
but taxes are a hard sell and then
there's a question which
you will sometimes hear people associate
with modern monetary theory and other
things
arguing which is it maybe we don't need
to raise taxes for them now a lot of
mmtr's would say
you can't do things this big without
raising taxes because you'll get
inflation so that's a that's an argument
as well
um but but that's my question for you
like do we need to figure out how to pay
for it because we have to figure out how
to pay for it
then it's going to be a um it's going to
force more choices and more sequencing
i agree with everything you just said
ezra and i also have seen the math
and i i know the price tags
on some of the things we're talking
about but one of the things i said to
folks
on the trail was what is the
cost of not addressing climate change or
what would the cost of climate change be
if we just let it
wreak havoc and ravage our country and
then people reflect on that for a second
most of them don't know you know the
size of the economy pre-pandemic was 22
trillion or so so if i
throw that in there then they say well
climate change is going to cost us
trillions of dollars
and thousands of human lives if we were
to do nothing and so then you start
thinking
okay the cost of inaction is in the
trillions
so then what is the benefit
of our investing in climate change
mitigation
particularly if you start measuring how
we're doing based upon how we are
actually doing as human beings like if
you have
a group of people drinking unclean water
or
having their town submerged you know
that that might not show up in certain
economic indicators
but it ought to so the the way i'd
answer your question
is to say that we should not be thinking
we can just do everything under the sun
in terms of putting it on the
government's
bottom line but we can be much much more
aggressive than we currently are
about making large-scale investments in
our own future in our infrastructure
addressing climate change and putting
universal basic income into our hands
because in many cases a lot of these
investments will end up
paying us back in both human ways and
economic ways
and the the argument i make on the trail
was that if you have
universal basic income in people's hands
does that improve our educational
outcomes
does that improve our health outcomes
does that reduce the cost
of incarceration does that improve
the ability of ex-convicts their ability
to reintegrate
into society like there are many many
things that we spend a ton of money on
right now
that we could reallocate or alleviate
if we invested directly in our people
and that was what a lot of people were
missing oftentimes
is that the investments you and i are
describing actually pay off and in many
cases pay for themselves
so i couldn't agree more on the
disastrously narrow way we think about
investment and particularly on climate
change
but that actually gets to to the core of
the series that this podcast is part of
about remobilizing the country
and on some of them we're not going to
be able to do everything
and so one of the things that i think
about if
i if it were up to me what would happen
first
i worry a lot about that long-term cost
of climate change i think people should
take a look around
at what coronavirus has done and then
recognize that climate change could do
that at much much larger scale for much
longer with an
endless ratchet into worse and worse and
worse outcomes
and so if you don't like this maybe like
let's not let that happen
as we think about or is the joe biden
administration or any administration
thinks about
what to do first there's going to be a
tension between the government saying
hey let's remobilize the economy to this
purpose
say a green new deal and climate change
or let's
you know just let's get money into
people's hands let's try to give people
demand-side stimulus let's mobilize
around things like cash
transfer payments uh who's been in the
ubi game for a long time
but also i think takes climate change
pretty seriously and takes preparing for
the future pretty seriously
what would you like to see happen first
i think we should be
investing in people immediately because
i'm terrified as to what's happening in
households and families around the
country
right now ezra where no it's a stressful
time for me and evelyn and my kids i'm
seeing my kids
suffer somewhat for the fact they just
don't see other kids
and i feel like we're very very
fortunate in the high side
if you look at the mental health
statistics
right now they're staggering in terms of
depression
use of the crisis text line like there's
just a lot of pain
right now and so the first thing we have
to do is make sure people can put food
on the table
and keep a roof over their head and not
have mass evictions
and the rest of it uh and so there are
the ways structural ways that you can
do that by for example continuing an
eviction moratorium but to me that
those are temporary measures in a way
that putting cash into people's hands
would be more direct obviously in my
case it would be
in perpetuity and i think you would see
a lot of folks have their heads up
very very quickly i also think that
having people
be able to meet their basic needs is an
accelerant for addressing climate change
because if you have everyone in a
position where they have to do whatever
the cheapest
thing is and they have no other choice
and then you you
um ask them to change their habits in
some way or
care about climate change even it's
actually much more difficult
the climate change investment and it's
related to this human well-being
question
we just need to create jobs in any way
we can i mean the the labor market
is in such a disastrous condition and so
if you can tie that to
infrastructure solar panels green new
deal like things that help us
modernize then i am all for it but you
shouldn't stop there like you you should
say
look over like if there's anything we
can do to get people
um into some kind of productive mindset
or environment then we should just do it
and and this is one thing where i think
it's very time sensitive
i'm hopeful that joe and kamala decide
to go big immediately
i always find that in politics there's
like an allergy this prioritization
conversation because on some level of
course you should do everything
uh like you can and everything you need
and
in my experience watching the way
administrations go
that ends up being a recipe for
neglecting long-term problems
so there's always a set of immediate
crises
right now more than at most times but
but always there's things people can
feel in the moment
and the endless problem of climate
change is that
as much as we can occasionally field in
the moment um
if i walk outside of my door right now i
will breathe in smoke
uh because california is now on fire
three months of every single year
as much as there are places where people
can feel it or can argue that they're
feeling it
they don't feel it in the way and it
cannot be as tightly coupled with
the pain they have as coronavirus as
losing a job
as losing health insurance and so we
always do the
the stuff that is right now the stuff
that
politicians think they're going to be uh
that will benefit them
in the next election because people feel
it right now first and then by the time
you've done that and
had those vicious battles and exhausted
your political capital and made people
take hard votes and had the chamber of
commerce spend 250 million dollars
against you
that long-term stuff you wanted to do is
just gone and so i think one of the
really hard questions for
abiding administration is going to be
whether or not they come in
and try to act first on something longer
term like climate change
uh at a moment wait maybe when it does
have a short-term power
because of the re-mobilizing
job-creating dimension of it or whether
they go
to uh relief and other things like that
first
um because if they do that it always
takes longer than you think and and
and you might end on the other side of
it without the political capital to do
to do the other things you want like how
do you think about the political
strategy of that
i appreciate what you're saying ezra and
i think the emphasis has to be jobs jobs
jobs
and you can get a lot of stuff done
while you're just talking about jobs you
can put cash into people's hands and say
this will be good for local businesses
which it will be
uh you can hire thousands of people
to go to our forest lands
and start actually trying to manage the
tinderbox that a lot of our forests have
become
because when i looked at the numbers i
think we
effectively manage less than 10 percent
of our forest right now because the u.s
forest service has not
been properly invested in and so joe and
kamala can say you know what we need
hundreds even thousands of uh people in
the forest service because we're trying
to create jobs like creating jobs
can seem universal and nonpartisan in a
really
effective way and it is so vital because
if someone's out of the workforce for a
while they then tend to drop
out and atrophy uh the human impact
can result in depression substance abuse
uh self-harm child abuse like like all
sorts of just really really nasty stuff
and everyone knows that josh you know
it's like you
like republicans also should get on
board with programs if you pitch it as
jobs jobs jobs and hopefully you can use
the jobs related pitch to try and
accomplish things around climate change
[Music]
one of the toughest things about this
time right now is taking care of
yourself
feeling healthy it's so easy to eat
poorly
right now i don't know about the rest of
you but i am not sure i've been getting
enough vegetation
in my diet and one way you can resolve
that
quickly efficiently in a way that's
doing your body right
is to use athletic greens so you mix it
with water
it creates this all-in-one drink it's
packed with
vitamins minerals everything your body
needs
and you can sense it you drink this
stuff and then your body's like what was
that
that actually was stuff that i need that
i never get
that's actually the sense you have so if
you want
to feel like you're treating your body
well in a way that's convenient
and efficient and will work for you
very very reliably go to
athleticgreens.com
yang and claim my special offer today
which is to receive
the free wellness bundle with your first
purchase that's
up to a one year supply of vitamin d and
added value when you try their
comprehensive daily all in one just do
it and you're done
you feel like you did yourself a service
all in one drink
again that's athleticgreens.comyang with
your first purchase with our discount
code they'll send you a free d3 k2
wellness bundle
which includes these basically vitamin d
drops and vitamin b12 drops that you
take they don't taste like anything but
you feel amazing like more energy just
like two drops done
athleticgreens.com yang claim this offer
it's pretty
we we literally do them ourselves it's
worth it guys check them out
[Applause]
one of the things that has often
appealed to people about ubi as i think
created a false sense the conservative
support ubi when
oftentimes if you look into those
proposals they they
collapse the rest of the state so you
can do ubi which i think is not
generally what what you and a lot of
progressives support
but something that people like about it
and cash transfer in general
is that it is a way of getting around
the inefficiencies
and lack of capacity of the state and i
mean you see this right now with how
much trouble state governments are
having doing
ui you see it with the complexity
particularly the rollout of obamacare
but but of obamacare in general
it is hard to make the federal
government work and doing things where
the federal government has to do a lot
of complicated things
it's even harder and there's possibility
for corruption and for self-dealing and
and all the stuff you read about in the
papers and meanwhile social security is
is a program that works really well and
so there's an appeal to going in that
direction
i'm curious as you were on the trail
unless you've thought about this and
somebody coming from a background that
was often very concerned with efficiency
in in the private sector how you think
about that
problem the deep lack of trust americans
often have in the federal government to
do hard things and the
more often than i think a lot of
progressives would like to admit
times when both state and federal
government
prove that mistrust had validity like
how do
how should a democratic administration
think about and address
that fundamental failure and
uh political problem this was one of the
big elements of my pitch to folks ezra
which is i said look
you know a lot of people are not that
confident in our government's
ability to take resources and deliver
value to you to us in a way that you'll
actually
feel and be able to utilize every single
day
but if it's in the form of cash in your
hands
then you'll be able to utilize it in a
way that you
know like benefits you the most like you
can solve your own problems
and there were a lot of folks who were
not
traditional dems who were very very
sympathetic to that
line of thought which i i happen to
believe and agree with and you talk
about
healthcare.gov um you know i was looking
into the
uh rollout which we all remember 2013.
boy do i remember that rollout yeah no
it's painful
you know and like you look at it and
it's not
exactly inspiring confidence uh in folks
um
and you have to take that to heart like
if you're
a democrat and progressive which i i
consider
myself you have to have ambition as to
what government can do but also a sense
of reality as to how
government can deliver that value to
folks and if
the government puts cash into people's
hands it's going to produce so
much value and also increased confidence
in government
among americans where you look up and
say well
the government got this right you know
like this cash certainly helped me a lot
and like i then turned around and bought
groceries or got my kid
uh you know a tutoring session or
whatever the heck it was
and that becomes a very very powerful
glue to help knit us back together
instead of just constantly saying don't
worry this stuff's happening
um and you should appreciate that it's
happening because i'm telling you about
it instead
you know it's something that they'll see
in their bank account
every month uh it's just a very very
different experience that i think can
actually bring the country together in a
powerful way my friend tyler
cowan who's a economist at george mason
university has a great podcast called
conversations with tyler i think one
would describe him as a
libertarian-leaning economist but
he's a very idiosyncratic political
thinker over the past
year he's made this argument for what he
calls state capacity libertarianism
which is a i think it's a little bit of
a strange idea that
he's arguing that libertarians should or
need to move in a direction of worrying
more about what the state can deliver
than just about how to take the state
apart
which i think uh for obvious reasons has
some has some issues
inside the libertarian coalition but
i've been thinking about
state capacity progressivism because i
think
people assume that like all
progressivism is
focused on state capacity and in my
experience it isn't at all
the progressives give very very little
thought to the capacity of the state to
accomplish their goals and this goes
from
how policymaking happens it's uh like
everybody knows
i am obsessive on the topic of the
filibuster because if you don't do
something about that you can't
pass any of the legislation not
literally any but
a lot of legislation we're talking about
is just dead letter the way the federal
government is structured the way
elections happen but then also within
the government itself how procurement
works um how regulatory feedback works i
mean there's a million things that are
really hard and over time have come to
work quite
badly and i think that progressives
overestimate how well the government is
actually working right now or at least
how old work have they controlled it
and that it would be good um i take the
point you're making here about a policy
feedback cycle where say a relief
payment creates a sense that the
government can actually help you and so
you should
trust the government to do more and
maybe you build up the ladder that way
but i also just wish i heard more from
democrats in power
about how you're actually going to make
the government work how it's going to be
able to absorb technology
faster how you're going to make it so
that congress
when you have power can actually return
and revisit legislation that can work a
little bit better how you're going to
make things just move a bit quicker
that we've gotten so trapped in this
government good or bad
argument that you end up having a lot
less focus and i think you need
given the size and complexity of
particularly progressive ambitions for
government
on how the government works and what do
you do
when it's not working how do you fix
that how do you identify it how do you
surface it
i think it has shown in our coronavirus
response really poorly
i cannot tell you how much i agree with
what you just said it is so important do
you have like a name for this school of
thought
right now because we need it really
badly there there's just like this
entire
government good government bad uh
argument and instead what
americans hunger for is smart effective
government
you know we can see that government has
become less effective certainly at the
congressional level very obviously
but also in other aspects and no one's
having
the right conversation around that so do
you have like a name for this concern
and a school of thought because i am 100
with you and i've been thinking about
the the exact same thing i i i i'll
think of naming i mean i feel like you
should give tyler collins i can't
believe that the term state capacity
libertarianism took off so maybe state
capacity progressivism will too
but i'll just say as on my soapbox here
for a minute this is why
it infuriates me
to see democrats so this appears to me
to be changing a bit now
but be so like a days ago in the
filibuster because what you're basically
saying there is as the party that tells
people government can work
you don't care that it doesn't as a
party that goes out in elections
and promises people all these amazing
things you're gonna do
you don't care that you're actually
gonna fail them or you don't care enough
to do anything about it you
you are more concerned about esoteric
and at this point what everybody agrees
are unbelievably misused um
old rules of the senate than about
delivering on all these crises many of
them literally life and death that
you've promised people
you'll do something about and so it's
just you know
what whatever the name for it i would
think it would actually just be like
what being a progressive or a democrat
is about
like a precondition to wanting to do all
these things through the government is
making sure the government can do things
in the first
place i mean i saw this mark in recent
piece a while back that got a lot of
attention the venture capitalists called
why we can't build
which is interesting and i wrote this
response to it which is simply that
a lot of why we can't build is it the
government and institutions
can't operate right like the you need to
take an institutional perspective
and i am really struck by how much
democrats uh
elected democrats here do not believe
what they say
they do not believe that the problems
they are facing are as bad
as they say on the stump and i'm talking
here mainly for senate democrats
because if they did if they did believe
this was all so important and get rid of
that they would get rid of the
filibuster and do a million other things
that would make government work better
procurement reform all these different
things like
if you care about things you figure out
how to make it work if you care about
talking about things and you don't worry
about that
operational and implementation side so
much ezra this is my new mission in life
which is to try and fix the mechanics of
our government so it can actually
deliver
to us because check it out i ran for
president
uh and you know you keep getting goaded
like you said into making these very
very grand statements
and then you start reflecting and i had
this reflection you can say whatever you
will about me on it but i had the
reflection
where i was like oh my gosh like if i
get into dc i need to deliver these
things
you know if you'd like like what's the
point of
making these arguments if you're
accepting a government that couldn't
deliver on them anyway
and so you need to get rid of the
filibuster you need to have
the operating system of government get
refreshed and updated
you you may not agree with this but i'm
for term limits in part for this reason
like the reason you described where you
have this gerundocracy
the average member of congress is 62 i
believe they don't understand what's
happening in most of the country
and the fact is their incentives are not
tied to whether we succeed or fail
anymore because
as long as they know they can't get
challenged in their district which a lot
of them can't be
because it's a safe district and you
know you've got like a seven digit cash
advantage to start with
then they can actually let us sink
further into the mud and keep their jobs
and they know that
uh and so the government failures that
we're talking about like i'm very very
passionate now about trying to actually
get in
and fix the mechanics that our
government can function
and that that's democracy reform that's
legislative
changes like you're describing that's in
my mind
term limits and i even have a clever way
that we can pass term limits
you say look everyone let's pass term
limits but current legislators are
exempt
and that way it's no skin off your back
it's gonna be the generation after you
but at least this way we can look
forward to
legislators that actually are just
trying to get stuff done and then
go home as opposed to crouching in dc
for decades at a time
i'm not a term limits fan for reason
i've argued on the ship but i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna get us in that
morass
um but i i think what you're saying in
general here is is really important
and i i just remember watching
2000 democratic presidential debates um
and you
lived through them in a much more
intense way than i did and just thinking
as people argued over like my new
questions
of like this medicare for all plan or
that medicare for most plan or
you know like this gun control plan that
won't pass or that gun control plan that
won't pass
that it was just a fantasyland debate
because until there was agreement even
just among democrats right who still
didn't even have control of the senate
right the the two questions that
mattered or the three maybe is like if a
democrat wins the white house so the two
next questions that matter for a
governing agenda
is did democrats win congress and did
senate democrats do something about the
filibuster
and if the answer to either of those
questions was no then
virtually everything else it got talked
about was gone
um not literally everything else some
stuff you could do the budget
reconciliation in a complicated way that
makes legislation a lot worse than it
would otherwise be so it's not a great
alternative but
there's some stuff you could do that way
but all the stuff about democracy reform
gun control like
everything that is an executive um uh
order
or a foreign policy decision is gone and
it would get like almost no discussion
and it again it all just struck me
sometimes as a very
i would call it unserious but it's
actually not harsh enough it was a
deceptive way of doing politics
it seemed like a bizarre theater
performance
and this is from someone who is part of
it and i would react to it being like
wow like these are our lines
like what's going on like what are the
stage directions
uh and so ezra i've got a name for this
like the mechanics you're talking about
in this movement it's like the let's get
real uh you know like let's stop playing
in fantasyland and say like okay like
what can we actually get done what are
the rules we need to change to get it
done
who do we need because so much of our
politics is degenerating
into value statements it's one reason
why
i think i seemed different is because
people kept sticking a mic in my face
and saying like make a value statement
make a value statement
it's like i'm just trying to solve
problems like the main problem i want to
solve is that people are poor for no
reason
uh and that if we we change that we
change a lot of other things very
positively including i believe
our fractured politics and at least in
some
some measure but you're like the let's
get real stuff i mean you're right like
if if if you have a filibuster it
doesn't matter if i change a couple
seats here and there like you you know
you're never gonna get to a threshold
where you can pass the filibuster
there's nothing in the constitution
about a filibuster it is just some weird
arcane
esoteric senate rule that took on a life
of its own
and so if you're willing to put that
rule above uh getting stuff done then
what are you doing there
[Music]
2020 is unfortunately a total disaster
for small businesses
you have to do anything you can to
survive
and one way that you can help your small
business is to make sure you can
efficiently
onboard folks when you need them quickly
indeed.com is the number one job site in
the world
because it gets you the people the hires
you need fast and if you're looking for
a job you go to indeed.com
and it has the employers who are looking
actively
right now for folks like you a lot of
these types of two-sided clearinghouses
benefit from volume
and indeed is the volume business they
have over three million businesses so if
you're looking for a job
they're the place to go and because of
that if you're looking to hire
people they're the place to go too they
have
over 70 percent of online job seekers
and over 3 million businesses
so you know the dynamics of these
clearing houses is that
when you get to a certain size it just
becomes more efficient and that's what
indeed has become
right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75 dollar credit to
boost your job post
which means more people will see it
quickly try indeed out with this free 75
credit at indeed.com yang this is the
best offer
available anywhere indeed.com yang terms
and conditions apply offer valid
just through the month of september
[Applause]
i want to talk about something else you
you brought to the debates it was always
my favorite my favorite part of the
andrew yang
um like subplot of democratic debates
which was
and we've touched on this already trying
to inject questions of technology into
them
um you often would do this when it came
to climate change talking about things
like fourth generation nuclear
and it happened pretty often and
something i've been reflecting on
on another track has been that a lot of
the problems that i care most about
solving
they have a huge technological dimension
to them i care a lot about animal
suffering and by far the most
uh promising way to do something about
that is plant and salvage meat
care a lot about climate change and
while i've had saul griffith on the show
talking about how we could fix climate
change without anything
any new technology being invented
there's just no doubt that given
the level of mandate and adoption and
take-up that we'll need if we can invent
some great new stuff it would become a
lot easier
ai often gets talked about in a dystopic
way but if we really could invent it
it could make life pretty amazing i'm a
big healthcare wonk um i've talked i've
like spent a lot of my career on health
insurance policy
but what the reason we care about health
insurance is it can make you healthier
and
what will make you healthier uh to some
degree is technological advances and
things like how we
fight cancer and you know handle gene
therapies
and other things and one of the things
that has struck me
is that i don't think progressives in
general
have much of a theory of technology
anymore um
i think that it's often talked about in
this dystopic way there's a lot of
frustration at the billionaires who who
own it
i often felt you sort of like oscillated
between like a very scary story about ai
and then also like a real interest in
technology as a way of solving problems
and i'd love to just hear you reflect on
that like what should what do you think
the political orientation
to technology in general should be i
love where you are on this ezra
like i i think that ideally progressives
are for progress
and you know what is going to enable a
ton of progress is technology
and one of the fun things about my
campaign was i was making some very dark
arguments about the impact of technology
which i completely believe
uh you know like if you have autonomous
trucks in the next
you know i'll extend the timeline
because i know you and i differ on this
but like
let's say like 20 years you know like
there'll be
millions of folks who uh used to drive a
truck for a living
who you know will need something else to
do so i like i believe all of that
wholeheartedly
but i also agree with you that if you're
trying to make people smarter
healthier mentally healthier trying to
clean up our planet
trying to feed people in a way that
doesn't brutalize animals
technology is a part of every single one
of those solutions in a very central way
and the one of the dangers to me about a
lot of our politics now is where we're
each arguing for different brands of
nostalgia
you know what i mean you know meanwhile
time only goes in one direction
you know it's 20 20. you're now out in
california
like i spent a lot of time there and
you go to some of the folks who are
working on the future and it is wild
like some of the things that they're
working on are very positive and
inspirational
some of them are very depressing and
dystopian but they're all
packaged together and we should not be
a group of people or a party that
also has our heads in the sand about the
positive and negative changes that
technology brings like we have to be the
party that
is hard-nosed and realistic but also
willing to embrace the
technologies that could lead us to
something that
more closely resembles utopia than this
current
mess we're living uh so i i love what
you just said ezra like uh
you know i completely agree like we need
to be embracing these technologies at a
much higher level and i'm
i may be a part of that in this next
administration
if um you know if we succeed in getting
trump out of there
wait uh i want to follow up on that
tantalizing i may be a part of that um
is there a job you've been talking about
oh so i've had just very very general
informal conversations with uh
the bind camp about trying to take on
some sort of technology-facing role
both some of the concerns that i
campaigned on and trying to address them
and one thing we haven't talked about
but i'm very passionate about that you
will be
too in a few years is the effect of
social media and technology on our kids
mental health you know like right now
you have massive levels of anxiety and
depression among teenage girls in
particular
in order to make certain companies like
facebook richer
which you know is not a good look but
our government is way behind the curve
on these issues
and i've offered my help in trying to
catch us up
and there's some interest uh in taking
me up on that
and so so then to go back to this
underlying question
you said something i thought that's
worth picking up on about you've talked
to people in silicon valley and you go
look at what they're doing and some of
it is very utopian and some of it is
very dystopian
and i've had probably some of the same
conversations with even some of the same
people you have and what always strikes
me
is that it's not in most cases intrinsic
to the technology which way that plays
out
and oftentimes it is actually about the
way the government
and both the rules of markets and and
regulations
but also to some degree government
implementation taxation etc
is going to interface with the
technology that's going to decide
whether it ends up being like utopian or
dystopian
and so there sometimes seems to me to be
a more obvious approach here
which is that i would say that it should
be a more
central priority
frankly for both parties to use the
government as a research
and innovation accelerant but then it
also has to be a more central
priority again hopefully for both
parties for
the government to have views and to to
care about how the technology is rolled
out who has access to it
and also what rules it operates under
um ai is a the most obvious example this
just given the the size of its potential
impact but there's a broad set of
problems right now where you know we
could
put a lot of money into say drug
development which we already do
and then insist on very different rules
for say how patents work
and how quickly things move to generic
bernie sanders i've always said this one
of my favorite healthcare policies of
his
going way back into senate career is
this idea to create prizes and not
patents
or at least a parallel track where we
would create you know prizes say five
billion dollars if you can create a drug
that does this thing
and then if you do it you get the five
billion dollars and the drug is generic
from the minute it goes forward and so
just like a much higher level of
sophistication with both how to
accelerate the advance of technology but
then also how to make sure its benefits
are more broadly shared
and its risks are attended to than we
currently have
um would seem wise to me yeah that
it's spot on ezra and
right now our government is out to lunch
on most of these technology issues
and we need to change it you know and i
agree with you this should be
central for both parties because the
rate of change is just getting faster
and faster
we got rid of the office of technology
assessment in 1995
25 years ago uh and we can all sense
that well there was no more technology
oh yeah no we invented everything 95.
ended in 95. it's embarrassing
really and we can all sense it like
everyone just has this collective groan
when it comes to
government and technology and then again
you have something like healthcare.gov
where you're like oh no
like they tried to make a website you
know
i mean i should have laughed because it
was freaking terrible um
so let me go let me go in on the
healthcare.gov thing for one second
because i did a lot of reporting on that
and and something that breaks my heart
about what has happened since then so i
did a
ton i wrote a business week cover on
this and like
the federal government's procurement
rules what was encoded into the
legislation
and then um just some of the ways the
agencies worked together who they could
hire when they could hire et cetera
it was all just built for disaster and
the obama station people just didn't
like
very few people saw this coming clearly
or they would have done something to
stop it
but in the aftermath of that
unbelievable catastrophe
they actually did a lot of really good
things they created this group 18f they
brought in a lot more software
development talent and began
using and at least i don't think they
ever got where they needed to go or
anywhere near it on
changing procurement particularly
procurement rules around software
which like you would never do
procurement um
for software in in like the private
industry the way the federal government
was like 1800 pages of procurement rules
it's wild i'm and and then it also meant
that the people who understood
how to navigate the procurement process
were not the best software developers
they were these massive consultancies
that had built that had like invested a
lot in lawyers to navigate the
procurement process so anyway
there was a lot that was happening on
that the i would say the obama
administration in the aftermath of that
catastrophe which was on their lap
did a lot of really good things in terms
of beginning to put seat you know put
ctos in the agencies and so on
procurement did not go through congress
in the way i was hoping it would
and then it just got destroyed under
trump i mean whatever progress was being
made and needed to be consolidated like
like the the world of 18f and things
like i'm i'm i still follow it somewhat
and it's been really
bad and i think that's one thing that is
a little bit under
um like underrated as one of the
disasters of this era
like whatever modernization was
happening in government just stopped and
we needed a lot more than was happening
but it's really a shame that we lost so
much of the progress that had begun
i couldn't agree more and that's
something that we should try and
rev up and invest in meaningfully i
looked into it too
uh the us digital service which did come
about uh in the aftermath of
healthcare.gov
it's still operating but it's down to
something like 180 people and if you
look at the scope of the federal
workforce i mean that's that's not
that's not enough to tell it there and
it's not empowered right those people
are not empowered yeah
and so they're they're often on
short-term stance but
even within their constraints they're
projected to
save something like 600 million dollars
in government costs and
in part because of the procurement
process you talked about so i
i'm with you that healthcare.gov
ended up leading to some real
modernization efforts that have now
stalled under trump that hopefully we
can get back to so if you were
helping to modernize government on
technology in a in a
future administration how would you
think about that where would you start
what would
what would be the kinds of things you
would imagine doing
you would ramp up the united states
digital service and empower it to your
point
and you and i both know that there are
hundreds maybe even thousands
of very talented technologists
designers coders who would help uh
government if they had
a runway to do so and felt like they
could actually be empowered as opposed
to going and just sitting in
meetings and getting their hands tied in
red tape and bureaucracy and the rest of
it
so instead of 180 you should have
something like
10 to 20 times that number of folks
uh working to help implement some of the
policies that folks are envisioning
for us digitally so that would be step
one you take what's been working
and then you pour fuel on it um that the
the other thing i would be trying to do
is um i think that there should be some
kind of west coast base of operation
in part as a talent enlistment move
because there are a lot of
techies that might not want to uproot
their families and head to dc and so you
need to give them a place to
reside and land and then we need to have
actual experts get into the guts of the
social media companies and the apps
because each of these companies
is its own thing like you you can't
really have one size fits all for
example 20th century anti-trust rules
when it comes to
you know facebook and instagram and the
rest of it though i do think that they
should not have allowed them to
acquire instagram um but that there are
all of these features that are companies
specif specific
that you need real expertise to try and
get to the bottom of and see if you can
curb the worst of the
excesses a lot of this conversation is
operated
in the like the implicit hypothetical
that joe biden wins because if he
doesn't most of the things we're talking
about are not going to happen
but imagining the alternative path what
do you think a second trump term would
look like
it would be catastrophic in my opinion
because
we're seeing the deterioration and
disintegration of our way of life
uh and i don't see that reversing itself
under trump
i think with joe and kamala it still
will not reverse itself
as if by magic but there's at least a
chance that we'll
get enough of a consensus to invest
trillions of dollars
in jobs infrastructure
economic relief uh health care
climate change mitigation you name it
like there's at least a chance i mean we
have a multi-trillion dollar hole that's
been blasted in our
annual economy and tens of millions of
us have gotten pushed to the side
uh and i said this in my dnc speech that
you know we have to give ourselves a
chance
and we at least get a fighting chance
with joe and kamala so
hopefully they're our next president and
vice president
you made a point during the zoom call
of former presidential candidates that i
thought was really sharp
about the ways in which biden has this
magical power you said
to when he endorses something it becomes
mainstream it becomes normalized
uh do you want to talk a little bit
about what you meant by that
yes the magic of joe biden is anything
he gets behind becomes the new
reasonable
that i really saw this when he proposed
this two trillion dollar
climate change plan that if
it had come out of bernie's mouth people
would have seen this extreme
but because it was joe i was like oh
yeah totally that's the thing to do
um and i also want to give credit to
david axelrod who said something similar
to me that i then ended up
parroting in that zoom round table but
joe's magic is that he has the potential
to be a transformative figure in terms
of policy
uh without ever actually coming across
as transformative it's a real
um it's a real gift he has
i'll ask you one more thing about a a
trump second term
during the campaign you talked a fair
amount about asian american
discrimination
you've wrote a washington post piece
about feeling after the coronavirus
that people were staring at you with
suspicion in a way that hadn't been true
before
there have been arguments about your
approach to this in in different ways
but
when you listen to trump during his
convention speech calling at the china
virus and saying that you know re-elect
him and he'll make sure to make china
pay
like how did that strike you personally
how did you
how did you see that playing out no i
felt like it was trump
reverting to his usual playbook of
distracting from his own failures by
calling attention to in this case what
he was characterizing as the kung flu
and
the china virus and the rest of it
certainly as an asian american it's
painful because there's always a sense
that somehow
your american-ness is in question and
having trump
double down on that is really
corrosive for the country but it's
painful for asian americans in
particular
and and i do feel like
our american-ness has been questioned
to a higher degree in the wake of the
coronavirus than has
been the case at really any point in my
memory the thing that
i was reflecting on after it
was when i started in politics as a
journalist sort of in the early 2000s
there was pre-9 11 but then very much
post 9 11
this hunger for an enemy and you know
people talked about the clash of
civilizations between you know the west
in islam
and and there's this real desire uh
particularly among i think politicians
who are comfortable in a cold war
consensus
and a cold war framework to find the new
external threat and i'm not a big fan
of china the way china withheld
information on the coronavirus
um and i'm certainly not a fan of their
movement towards authoritarianism what
they are doing to the uyghurs you can
listen to past episodes of the show on
this
but i'm really pretty scared of and i
think it would be very
prominent in a second trump term this
idea that you want to create
an oppositional relationship between
america
and china in particular but but arguably
the
asia more generally that politicians who
see their own political safety in
creating an enemy and creating fear in a
world where we have to actually work
together on threats like coronavirus
future pandemics things like that
it just it's such the wrong lesson to me
and it's such a potentially dangerous
thing that i feel like people don't
actually
talk about it that much because i think
properly one's
feelings towards china right now should
be somewhat complicated at least on a
policy level not towards people there
but nevertheless very little would be as
bad
as america and if people have not really
like lived through this in washington i
don't think you realize how quickly can
happen
as a clash of civilizations narrative
becoming the dominant for the dominant
foreign policy framework
now not towards the middle east because
like that didn't turn out to be
what they needed to be to keep um
driving american politics for decades
and decades but now towards china
i i agree with you on all fronts ezra
you and i agree on a lot of things who
knew
there's too much agreement in this
conversation it's a disaster no uh yeah
i know
we'll we'll think of something to
disagree on momentarily
but a few things number one is we all
know that there's a military-industrial
complex that
likes to keep us engaged so we say in a
way to spend the 700 billion dollars
like a friend of mine who's an engineer
at uh one of the big aeros
aerospace companies at the end of the
cold war said that they actually came
together in a rumor like all right who's
next we're gonna be with
you know i mean it's very dark like
those are kinds of things you
um you hear from folks who are attached
to the industry
and i agree with you that trump's
playbook is to find an enemy and in
in this case it's it's going to
naturally
um head towards china and the east
to disastrous consequences and the goal
should be to
and i agree it's a very very complex
fraud relationship with some massive
massive
problems and concerns around the things
you described
and then some like their theft of our
intellectual property
massive massive problem but
you need to have some kind of
relationship with china in order to
guard against the next pandemic
to make progress on climate change to
make progress on data and
ai concerns to make progress on north
korea
but you know like that there is a much
less
safe world if you aren't in touch with
the chinese government to the point
where you even can speak to them about
something that's happening that uh would
concern american well-being so
that that's a reality uh and
unfortunately we are getting to
a point now where uh where folks
feel better served politically by trying
to present
like a different version of reality for
purposes that you know may benefit
them their party ex certain economic
interests but are really bad for
all of us long term uh and to your point
too
as someone who grew up in this country
you know one of like the
simmering fears you have as an asian
american is that like uh if you wind up
with like a u.s china geopolitical
conflict
that like asian americans will end up
being uh caught right in the middle let
me ask you
one more question uh that's political
before we wrap up we'll have to wait for
more disagreement for the next podcast
uh which is as somebody who's a newcomer
to the institutional democratic party i
think you've probably voted democrat
before but but but being involved in it
as a political actor i think is newer to
you
and came in from the outside of it what
is one
mistake you wish democrats would stop
making a habit or idea that you
that you would advise them to drop like
what is one way you'd like to change the
democratic party
wow ezra i like this question and
you know it's it's been a real learning
journey for me i said this in another
context but
i think democrats need to figure out why
it is that many working-class americans
do not feel like
we are fighting for them or we stand for
them and i ran into this all the time on
the trail
like a waitress or truck driver or a
retail clerk um
when they found out i was a democrat
like it's like i
had said a dirty word and i thought to
myself well how was this
like you know you're uh trucker waitress
uh clerk like shouldn't you be who we
are fighting for
like shouldn't everything i'm talking
about actually be appealing to you
and i think we've gotten caught in these
exchanges that don't actually
feel like they're relevant to
those folks and we need to get better at
it
you know i think unfortunately
republicans
have become more effective at
communicating to certain groups of
people
than we have and instead of saying well
it's their fault like we should
do some soul searching and be like why
is it that they don't think that
we're speaking to them and one of the
things i said in another environment was
that like we do not want to be
characterized as the
party of the educated elite uh or folks
who just live in big cities
because if that's the case then trying
to reach folks
that we're going to need to reach around
the country is going to be very very
difficult
so that that would be one big message
i'd have and and i
i'm obviously like on board with a lot
of the policy prescriptions
that we have i just want to try and
present them to folks in a way that
makes them feel
makes it feel like it's going to touch
them and improve their lives every
single day
and it doesn't seem as top-down it's
more bottom-up and this goes back to
your earlier point before about
good uh you know good government um
not so good government it's like uh like
we we can't get
trapped in these abstractions we have to
try and translate it
into the concrete and the direct and
that includes
getting to a point where we can be
realistic about uh how to deliver value
to people that's where we'll leave it so
now the final question is always what
are three books you've read that you'd
recommend to the audience
so a few books uh i've i've read
recently that i enjoyed and got a lot
out of
the first is humankind by rutger bregman
and he's probably read this one
wrecker is one of the universal basic
income not just not just to annie but
rutgers was on the show a couple
months ago now what is time but
uh but yeah it's a good book yeah good
stuff so the great thing about humankind
is it makes you question
human nature itself like uh you know are
we as
bad as all a lot of uh you know folks
would have us believe maybe not
uh so that that book was edifying
and enlightening i really enjoyed zucked
by roger mcnamee
so if you care about what's going on
with facebook it's a really
easy to read narrative about one
investor's
uh skepticism towards facebook that grew
into more than skepticism it actually
started from non-skepticism to
skepticism to
uh fear and activism and so if you're
concerned about facebook
zucked is a good book to read and then
the third thing i'd recommend which is
probably near and dear to your heart
ezra
is they do not represent us by lawrence
lessig
and it's about democracy reform and how
our
representative government may not be
that representative
and he started with problems around
campaign finance reform which
are fundamental but then he goes into
various structural reforms around the
need for rank choice voting and other
things
and i am a huge fan of lawrence's
argument uh it's something that i
believe we need to be paying more
attention to andrew yang thank you very
much
thanks ezra always a pleasure i
appreciate you thank you for listening
in i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]